all right so
uh tell me if i get the question right
again so the question was
like uh
some sort of coordinate coordination
issue arises and you can't get the
technique yes sensei if you want to
elaborate go ahead it's what it feels
like i don't know if it's because i'm
just tensing up okay so we have tension
there okay okay
um
here's some things to note all right uh
juju we're just going to call it by its
modern nomenclature jiu-jitsu okay
so aikido is a jiu-jitsu okay
there's a lot of people that want to
draw distinctions
you know between the doe ending and the
jitsu ending
and stuff like that it's just it's
historically inaccurate okay
the idea that you could use
a martial art
as an equivalent to
buddhist training
you see
preceded
the
formation of the
budo in japan
so aikido
kendo kyudo judo those things do you
understand that
and
trying to draw a distinction between
the jiu jitsu is like hardcores it's all
martial it's just marshall and the doe
arts are spiritual this is not this is
not true this is inaccurate okay you got
it so uh there were many different arts
they go by many different names
uh but at the same time
they're not really
sharing
the same kind of genealogical branch
karate
you see
so these arts that have a common
genealogy that go by many many names
we're just going to use the modern
nomenclature as jiu-jitsu
and aikido is a jiu-jitsu
okay
these arts
are
an
extension or an alignment they're an
extension of or an alignment of
early early early chinese thought and
in particular the idea that there is
a kind of identifiable
nature
things in alignment
with that nature
are better than things out of alignment
with that nature okay so your jujitsu
shares this genealogy
and therefore it's going to use
natural movements
not unnatural movements so it's going to
um
work with how your body's your body
works
not only in terms of the mechanics of
say for example the elbow joint do you
see that but you will do things you will
share movements with other ways that you
move outside of a martial context
do you get it so i want to drink water
do you see i want to drink water
and or i want to get the
the crap out of my hair
do you understand so
he's here
and uh
i want to drink water
i'm drinking water
do you see i want to get the stuff out
of my head oh
it's natural okay
um i want a kick
it's just an extended step
okay so
i don't want to kick like this
my my
my foot follows
a natural
direction with no dva if you if you walk
like this i guess that would be in
coordination with this but if i'm just
walking walking a kick
is a natural extended kick all right
foot uh walk do you get it so
uh we won't do this stuff
we don't do that stuff okay
this is the slight knee bend of the walk
keeps its place and if i want it higher
the hip lifts
lifts up
this way okay
etc
i stand i have a natural stance you see
i'm not going to
you know
do this stuff or
this i'm not gonna do that okay
um which is why you can practice your
jiu-jitsu
for a very very long time because it
doesn't require
an excessive
flexibility
or mobility
do you understand
okay
and that is why
usually
when you can't
do the move in a way that you would
describe
as a coordination
problem
there's only two reasons why
you you walked here
in a very unusual way
do you get it
or
you're not doing the move as it is
prescribed
okay
well you walked here
in a very natural way do you see common
with a bipedal
organism in common with how everyone
walked here within some sort of spectrum
do you see
um
so
i'm doing it
incorrectly not in accordance with this
natural way do you see that okay
so oh there's only so many reasons why
okay but they all come to the same place
all right so as i watch
your technique and all of your
techniques
um
it's very key to
the tension that you're feeling
in other words why can't i do an
unnatural movement
without the tension
it's always there
do you see that it is it is
physiologically possible to do an
unnatural movement without the tension
but we never do
do you see that so
what we tend to think is
uh we put the we answer the the horse
and the cart riddle incorrectly you see
it's because you're tense
and you can't do a natural movement you
your tension
and what causes the tension
prohibits you
in a very
direct way ultimately from doing what
would have been natural to you
do you get it so for example
um uh
taking out all physiological deviation
and i'm in the spectrum of head neck
shoulder area we all generally look like
this
no one
no one did that no one does this do you
see
i did it
do you get it
i i do it out of fear
okay
it's not that if i had a physiological
thing where i keep doing it that's one
thing but that's not what's happening
and it's a fear response you get its
anxiety that happens
okay
well
if you look now for your whole technique
and you look for
the anxiety
do you see you're going to see
even where you would not say your tense
and uncoordinated
you would see the anxiety
do you get it so he's he's from this
side he's going to lay on me in the lord
do you see how he does does this look
normal no no it's like
do you want do you understand right
and then uh even let's say uh he's on
the bottom
and i'm going to do the move and i'm
like
do do i look if you take him out of the
way
and you're like
dave make yourself comfortable feel free
to lay on the mat
[Laughter]
relax
dude do you see that
okay so uh
again if you you're tracking for anxiety
i don't have any anxiety right now
okay
and sensei says okay we're going to work
from side control
oh god
that's not my normal mouth i'm doing
something dc
and then your your guy comes on you
and you're like
it's big ronin
right
he crushes me look at me
[Laughter]
do you understand
so
the anxiety has a catalyst
there to get it it's not natural it's so
it's not
constantly existing it manifests in
response to certain things
okay and if you track for the anxiety
you can track where it is if where is
genesis rest
okay and so here you are
and uh you you it doesn't take
a genius to figure out what is going on
right so depending on who's doing it
um
you can find
common
points of anxiousness
okay
so it might be the opposite gender
because you still live dichotomously
do you see
it might be the same gender because you
still live dichotomously
all right and it might be either a
repulsion or an attraction they're both
dichotomous thinking they're both going
to generate the tension
you see
um
you might have uh got
crushed
they're they're heavy do you see
and uh because you had someplace else
you'd rather be
again dichotomous thinking you see as
opposed to uh i'm i'm fine
dude so you saw me doing the weight on
him he's basically breathing out of the
snorkel if he listened right he's over
because he's being crushed
but did you see that the tension in his
body it was like
talk as long as you want i can breathe
you see but most of us will it knows too
much that's not how i want to breathe i
want to breathe like this and it causes
tension
and now you can't breathe let me see
um
today i i um
you know as as i have taught uh the
newaza for a long long time
the biggest
obstacle
is the same obstacle in tachiwaza is
this
that you always
are tense
and look to overpower
okay
um
or look to not be overpowered
but
the problem here is that your
these arts these jiu jitsu
don't work through overpowering
or
trying not to be overpowered they work
through non-contestation
and the only true non-contestation
it can only exist
when you have reconciled dichotomy
so if you get triggered into a
dichotomous mindset you by default you
cannot do aikido it is absolutely
impossible and don't forget you can't do
any of the arts
that are of this genealogy so while
there's plenty of bjj people that are
looking and puffing and muscling
everything it's not bjj
it's
not just like
contesting in your aikido kihon waza
tachiwaza is not aikido
it's crappy aikido
huffing and puffing and muscling in bjj
is this crappy bjj
it's not
okay
so it's very
when we do these kind of very controlled
kihon waza training right or we string
together some kihomaza
you have to
monitor for
anxiety
and the dichotomy that is giving birth
to it
and you have to use these opportunities
where it's not live rolling do you see
you have to use these opportunities
to get used
to what you'd rather be abhorred by
do do you understand that so when when
when uh
this guy comes go ahead do all your
technique do do it clean okay so he's
he's you can already hear my voice
change do you see
and uh i there's let's for example do
your take don't let me get you don't let
me get you you see
there's nothing i can do okay and
there's nothing i'm supposed to do in
this kilowata dc so watch watch my whole
demeanor
start to change
got it
if you want a reference point
you all know corpse pose
and corpse pose is this releasing
you can do
corpse pose here
by letting this
potential catalyst
present itself
and you release yourself from it
okay
and i guarantee you
you will then find the natural way of
moving there is only one way that's
gonna make sense to you
okay it's it's your
and if you don't buy this then you
should not train in jiu jitsu because
this is the genealogical source of jiu
jitsu is there is a natural way this and
it's better to be in accordance with
this natural way
the dow
you see if you don't buy
that
nor
do you buy
that if you go out of accordance of it
then everything starts
continually becoming more and more
compounded negatively
if you don't buy that one you don't you
should stop training you don't you can't
do this you don't have enough faith in
this position on the nature of reality
okay
so
if you do have enough faith
then if i tell you
get
use the training
to release yourself from the catalyst
that's causing the anxiety and you will
find the technique because there will be
no other way that your body will want to
move
you see right now it wants to move
differently because you will not free
yourself from the catalyst of the
anxiety
do you understand
okay so that is how i would answer your
question you want to fix your technique
right yes okay so
it's not going to be a matter of going
put your knee here put your foot here
because we had
advanced students over you telling you
that it doesn't work
okay
it
goes deeper the problem is deeper which
is precisely why
a martial art can be an equivalent to
the buddha's path
you see